hi there Steve Kaufman here I'm back
from my visit to rarotonga New Zealand
and Australia and so I today I want to
talk about linguists linguist because
that always generates a lot of
controversy people criticize me for
calling speakers of many languages
linguists even though that's the most
common definition in the dictionary most
people don't know the meaning of the
word polyglot or the people that I speak
to UM going to talk about linguists
because on my trip here as is always the
case i met with people in New Zealand
and Australia therefore in Auckland
melbourne sydney and brisbane who are
Keener's on learning languages and very
competent and in many cases they learned
three four or five languages and speak
them very very well some of them have a
monolingual background some of them were
born into a situation where they heard
many languages it doesn't seem to matter
the overwhelming factor of success is
their enthusiasm and their interest now
in that regard I want to mention where
for talking about linguists or polyglots
or for that matter hyper Glotz I want to
refer back to the book that I reviewed
on my blog which was called Babel no
more which is written by Michael L art
and it's about people who speak you know
10 languages or more whom he calls hyper
glance I want to talk about that because
in about a week's time or so I'm going
to be participating in a television
program here in Canada on global
television with some other Canadian
hyper Glotz and we're going to talk
about why we're so interested in
learning languages so kind of to prepare
myself for that I have been listening to
the polyglot podcasts and I'm going to
post this is a
an initiative of of Claude good boy
David mansaray I remember his name
pardon me here and it's Claude
vertiginous pronounce his name but I
think his vertiginous he is the person
put together this book which is a
compendium of the stories of different
polyglots for my car linguists but I
accept the word polyglot and David and
Claude interview people who are in fact
polyglots and there's a real sort of
all-star cast here of people that they
have interviewed Moses McCormack dr.
Peter Brown Kathleen herons Susan
zorroski Robert Bigler Richard sim card
and Luka lumpy lor Luka with whom I had
those conversations that you may have
listened to here at my channel at
YouTube well I'm going to be talking to
Richard simca this sunday and will
probably speak a little in English about
language learning and and one other
language I I've asked him if we can talk
in Russian because when i did my
previous discussion with luca we started
running out of time because we were
speaking all of these languages one
right after the other and i had to run
off to watch my grandson play hockey and
so I started getting more and more
anxious and so I think we kind of
compressed each language to fewer and
fewer minutes and the Russian and the
Swedish and the Chinese kind of got
short shrift so I might just start out
with if Richards okay i know he speaks a
number of slavic languages i'm not sure
whether he speaks Russian but see what
he wants to do i'm i'm easy on that
score there was a criticism that us
polyglots our linguists only ever talk
about language learning in these
different languages and they would like
us to cover other ground so again that's
up to Richard but we will find a common
language whether it be Russian or some
other language and maybe talk about some
other subject we'll see how that goes
and I think with Richard to will
probably go one or two languages a week
rather than trying to do them all at
once
because it gets a bit tiring after a
while you know one hour on skype gets a
bit tiring so that's coming up but in
preparation to some extent in
preparation for my discussion with
Richard and also in preparation for the
television program next week I have
started listening to these podcasts the
polyglot pod gasps they were also
mentioned at our forum on link so I I
must tell you they're very very
interesting and I recommend that if you
have the time listen to them now they're
fairly long so what I do is I download
them and I listened to them to them in
my car I had to drive downtown today and
and so I got a fair amount of it you
know in me while driving and then around
the house rather than listening to
russian or czech while doing the dishes
i listen to richard sim card and luca
lamp are yellow here so I very much
recommend us to them because because
what's interesting about them is that
they are each person's personal story i
must say that David and and Claude and
especially David because he's done the
last two alone he's a really good
interviewer and he brings out their
story in a very interesting way and he
has almost like a radio announcers voice
so the whole thing is quite entertaining
and all these people are very you know
capable of explaining you know the
reason why they were interested what
they did and so forth I find that that
depending on who is being interviewed i
agree with you know 30 40 50 eighty
percent of what they say but inevitably
have areas where i don't agree and but
where we all come together i shouldn't
say all because i haven't heard everyone
here but of the ones that i've heard
particularly richard and luca is that
they say as i say you know do what you
like to do and there are many different
ways of achieving success so and you
know these people all have slightly
different paths to to achieving their
success in learning different languages
I I don't to put words in their mouth
but I think they kind of all implied
that anyone can do it that it's not a
matter of some genetic predisposition I
think they would agree maybe not I
shouldn't assume again but certainly
they what they had to say confirmed in
my mind that the three great sort of
keys to language learning still apply
the number one is that your motivation
your attitude your passion they all talk
about this your confidence your whole
mindset towards language learning is the
overwhelming factor and if you have that
interest and that's obvious by listening
to these people that they all had this
passion as I do particularly my later
years here for learning languages and
the confidence and that they liked the
language again Richard goes into this
whole idea again of loving the language
at its armies from listening to the
others that they love learning these
languages so the attitude is absolutely
paramount the second thing is that you
have to put in a time if you listen to
them they have all put in a lot of time
there is no you know other than daniel
Tammet who has some unique artistic
ability to learn most people put in a
fair amount of time but again in order
to put in the time you have to like what
you're doing and so that's why you know
some of the specific techniques that
Luca uses or richer users or or some of
the others use Susannah and so forth I
wouldn't I don't like doing those things
and therefore those are not things that
I would do so in order for me to be able
to put in the time I've got to do the
things that I like to do in the sequence
that I like to do and this is another
thing that's some some of us I mean we
all like to talk but you know at what
point we all recognize the need to refer
to grammar in some way whether we're
specifically looking at grammar
explanations or whether we are studying
as Luca does the language he's learning
and comparing it to a language he knows
very well in order to
identify the structural differences and
how concepts are presented in the new
language whatever it is you have to have
some way that you're dealing with the
issue of of grammatical structure but we
can all do it our own way in a way that
we like so again to kind of repeat it
you got to have that attitude you got to
put in the time and then the third thing
is you've got to find some way of
helping your brain notice what's going
on hopefully a way that you like but
this then it gets back to the idea of
you know Lucas techniques both Luca and
Richard liked bilingual text I don't I
find them distracting but everyone is
you know they are very successful
polyglots linguist more successful than
I am I don't know whether on a per you
know unit of time input basis they are
but in terms of the net result they
certainly are more proficient than I am
in most languages so you know their
system works for them I don't like doing
it so it wouldn't work for me so but I
recognize that I have to do things to
help me notice for example one thing
I've started doing now in my Russian
when I read away from the computer since
I now know you know I very few words if
I'm reading through coast or I'm reading
out a book by rosinski advances key on
the history I think the biography of
Alexander the second I go through there
and I have decided to give each case in
Russian a number nominative is one
accusative his two genitive is three
dative is for instrumental is five and
the prepositional case is six so I write
in a little number 136 right above the
nouns and adjectives and if it's plural
I write it twice what does it do it
forces me to think about the structure
it forces me to get a grasp not only of
that specific adjective and noun but of
the overall way these things work I
understand it in principle I have for
many years but I have trouble nailing
them down when I'm speaking I regularly
make mistakes with my cases so I'm now
forcing myself to pay attention
so this is again a way to increase our
ability to notice Luca has techniques
with regard to working on your
pronunciation obviously you have to
notice you have to hear the
pronunciation otherwise you can't
imitate it so again in listening to
these I recommend that you listen to
them I've enjoyed them and they have
only confirmed me in my belief that the
big three attitude time on task and
improving your ability to notice are the
keys and that the way we do that can
vary from individual to individual and
yeah there we are and the polyglots
linguists are all over the world
everywhere I go I meet them and it's not
something that we are born with and some
kind of a genetic gift it's it's very
much something that we're all capable of
doing so thank you for listening and if
you have any specific subjects that you
would like me to raise with Richard sim
card when we speak on Sunday please let
me know bye for now